It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago. I'm Susan Burton sitting in for Ira Glass today. There are these videos I've been watching-- videos of female politicians telling very personal stories. Here's one of them. It shows Gretchen Whitmer. She's now the governor of Michigan, but she's speaking here a few years ago when she was a member of the state legislature.
这是来自WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》。我是苏珊·伯顿，今天代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。我一直在看一些视频——视频里的女性政治家讲述着非常私人的故事。这是其中之一。视频中是格蕾琴·惠特默。她现在是密歇根州州长，但她在这里发言时是在几年前，当时她是州议会议员。
I've said it before, and I will say it again. This is by far one of the most misogynistic proposals I've ever seen in the Michigan legislature.
我以前说过，我还会再说一遍。这是我见过的密歇根州议会中最厌女的提案之一，没有之一。
Whitmer's explaining why she's voting no on a bill that would forbid women from using insurance to cover abortions, unless they bought separate abortion insurance, what Whitmer calls "rape insurance."
惠特默正在解释她为何投票反对一项法案。该法案禁止女性使用保险支付堕胎费用，除非她们购买了单独的“堕胎保险”，也就是惠特默所说的“强奸保险”。
And for those of you who want to act aghast that I'd use a term like "rape insurance" to describe the proposal here in front of us, you should be even more offended that it's absolutely accurate description of what this proposal requires. This tells women that were raped and became pregnant that they should have thought ahead and bought special insurance for it.
对于你们中那些因为我用“强奸保险”这个词来描述眼前的提案而感到震惊的人，你们应该对这个提案所要求的内容感到更加愤怒，因为它确实是对此最准确的描述。这实际上是在告诉那些被强奸并怀孕的女性，她们本该提前预见到这种情况并为此购买特别保险。
She's been talking for several minutes, when suddenly she stops, sets her papers down.
她讲了几分钟后，突然停了下来，放下手中的讲稿。
I have a lot more prepared remarks here, but I think it's important for me to just mention a couple of things. So I'm about to tell you something that I've not shared with many people in my life. But over 20 years ago, I was a victim of rape. And thank god it didn't result in a pregnancy, because I can't imagine going through what I went through and then having to consider what to do about an unwanted pregnancy from an attacker.
我还有很多准备好的发言稿，但我认为我有必要提几件事。我现在要告诉你们一些我人生中从未向许多人透露过的事情。但在20多年前，我曾是强奸案的受害者。感谢上帝，那次遭遇没有导致怀孕，因为我无法想象在经历了那一切之后，还要考虑如何处理攻击者留下的意外怀孕。
The whole time Wittmer talks, she grips the sides of the lectern. Her face looks like she's in pain.
惠特默说话时，双手一直紧紧抓住讲台边缘。她的脸看起来像是承受着巨大的痛苦。
I am not enjoying talking about it. It's something I've hidden for a long time, but I think you need to see the face of the women that you are impacting by this vote today. I ask that my comments be my no vote explanation.
我不喜欢谈论这件事。这是一件我隐藏了很久的事情，但我认为你们需要看看今天你们的投票所影响的女性的面孔。我要求将我的这番评论作为我投反对票的解释。
My no vote explanation, she says. Whitmer's story wasn't planned. She said later that she decided to tell her secret in that moment, standing at the mic. As soon as she left the floor and got into her car, Whitmer called her father. She'd never told him that she'd been raped. She didn't want him to hear about it on the news that night. She hadn't expected to tell the Michigan legislature before she told him.
她说，这是她投反对票的解释。惠特默的故事并非事先计划好的。她后来表示，她是站在麦克风前的那一刻决定讲出这个秘密的。她一离开议会大厅坐进车里，就给她的父亲打了电话。她从未告诉过他自己曾被强奸。她不想让他当晚通过新闻得知这件事。她没料到会在告诉他之前先告诉密歇根州议会。
I wondered if the call to her father was harder. I think it's sometimes easier to tell a secret in public than in private-- safer to have that distance. When I first saw Whitmer's video a year ago, I was on the verge of revealing a secret in a very public way in a book that was about to be published. I'd written a memoir about my eating disorder. And until recently, that eating disorder, it had been a secret from everyone in my life.
我曾想过，告诉她父亲是不是更难。我觉得有时在公共场合说出一个秘密比在私下里更容易——有那种距离感会更安全。一年前，当我第一次看到惠特默的视频时，我正准备在一本即将出版的书里以非常公开的方式揭露一个秘密。我写了一本关于我饮食失调的回忆录。直到最近，那种饮食失调一直是我生活中对所有人保守的秘密。
Sometimes people say "everyone," and then follow it with an "except," like, except my mom and my best friend. I really do mean everyone. Not even my husband knew, and we'd been together for 25 years. I never talked about it, and I'd also never been in therapy for it. When I finally did seek help, I was 45.
人们有时会说“所有人”，然后后面跟着一个“除了”，比如，除了我妈和我最好的朋友。我是真的指所有人。连我丈夫都不知道，而我们已经在一起25年了。我从未谈论过它，也从未因此接受过心理治疗。当我最终寻求帮助时，我已经45岁了。
In the very first session, my therapist, trying to get the story straight, or maybe just trying to get me to hear how absurd this sounded, said, you wrote a whole book about this, but you've never talked about it with anyone? That was right. I'd gone to see the therapist partly because it did seem kind of messed up to me, what I'd done. I knew it was just as urgent to understand my relationship with secrets as my relationship with food. That's where I was when I watched Whitmer's speech, thinking a lot about secrets and why we tell them and the form they take when we do.
在第一次咨询时，我的治疗师为了理清故事，或者仅仅是想让我听听这听起来有多荒谬，她说，你写了一整本关于这个的书，但你却从没和任何人谈论过它？那是对的。我去找治疗师的部分原因是因为我觉得我所做的那些事确实有点乱套了。我知道了解我与秘密的关系和我与食物的关系一样迫切。当我看惠特默演讲时，我就是这种状态，我思考了很多关于秘密的问题，为什么我们讲述它们，以及当我们讲述时它们以何种形式呈现。
What made Whitmer's speech so powerful was that her secret was not just a confession. It was an argument. It was told to persuade. I was moved by her video, and I went looking for others like it. Of course, politicians tell personal stories and speeches all the time, but disclosing something you've kept private for years and doing it in a legislative session, sometimes spontaneously, that's pretty new. Almost every example I turned up was about sexual trauma, which, I mean, there are a bunch of reasons for this, but a big one is the increasing number of bills that try to restrict access to abortion.
惠特默演讲的力量在于，她的秘密不仅仅是一次坦白。它是一次论证。它是为了说服而讲述的。我被她的视频打动了，于是我开始寻找其他类似的视频。当然，政治家们一直在演讲中讲述个人故事，但在立法会议上披露你隐藏多年的事情，有时还是自发的，这相当新鲜。我找到的几乎每一个例子都是关于性创伤的，对此有很多原因，但其中一个主要原因是越来越多的法案试图限制堕胎途径。
I watched videos from all over the country-- Victoria Steele in Arizona, Theresa Fedor in Ohio, Mandy Wright in Wisconsin, Nancy Mace in South Carolina. One of the things I wondered about was what prompted them to speak. Like what exactly made them stand up and say it? A couple said they were infuriated by the conversation in the room, comments like women lie about being raped. And I wondered what it felt like to say the secret.
我看了来自全国各地的视频——亚利桑那州的维多利亚·斯蒂尔，俄亥俄州的特蕾莎·费多尔，威斯康星州的曼迪·赖特，南卡罗来纳州的南希·梅斯。我好奇的一件事是，是什么促使她们站出来发言。比如到底是什么让她们站起来说出这一切？有几位说，她们被议事厅里的谈话激怒了，比如“女性在强奸问题上撒谎”之类的言论。我很好奇，说出这个秘密是什么感觉。
When Yuh-Line Niou disclosed to the New York state assembly that, at age 13, she'd been abused by a teacher, she drew attention to what was happening in her body as she spoke.
当余林·纽向纽约州议会披露她13岁时曾受到老师虐待时，她一边讲述一边引起了人们对她身体反应的注意。
I never speak on this bill for this reason because I literally can't stop shaking. Thank you so much.
我从不因为这个原因对这项法案发表意见，因为我真的无法停止颤抖。非常感谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Just a couple of weeks ago, there was another similar video that got a lot of attention from New York Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez. She was talking about the riot at the Capitol, and then she revealed this.
就在几周前，还有另一个类似的视频引起了广泛关注，来自纽约州女众议员亚历山德里娅·奥卡西奥-科尔特斯。她在谈论国会大厦的骚乱时，透露了这一点。
I'm a survivor of sexual assault, and I haven't told many people that in my life.
我是性侵犯的幸存者，在我的人生中，我没告诉过很多人这件事。
Ocasio-Cortez didn't say this in a legislative session. Her video was on Instagram Live. But it felt like the others I'd watched in that she was using her secret to make an argument-- in this case, about the impact of trauma. That different kinds of trauma compound on each other. She and the others spoke out because there was something important at stake. They disclosed their secrets as a public service.
奥卡西奥-科尔特斯并非在立法会议上说出这些。她的视频是在Instagram直播中播放的。但它给人的感觉和我看过的其他视频一样，她利用自己的秘密来进行论证——在这种情况下，是关于创伤的影响。不同种类的创伤会相互叠加。她和其他人站出来发言是因为有重要的事情处于危险之中。她们披露自己的秘密是为了公共服务。
Of course, for most of us, the reasons we tell secrets, they're not as straightforward. My own reasons for telling my secret, I can't even call them reasons. That's too rational. What I had was an urge to tell, one driven by desperation, obsession, anger, a longing to be known and understood. There are all kinds of secrets and all kinds of reasons for telling and not telling. That's our show this week-- why we tell secrets and what happens after we do. Stay with us.
当然，对于我们大多数人来说，我们讲述秘密的原因并不那么直截了当。我自己讲述秘密的原因，我甚至不能称之为“原因”。那太理智了。我所拥有的是一种讲述的冲动，一种由绝望、执念、愤怒、渴望被了解和理解所驱动的冲动。秘密有各种各样，讲述和不讲述的理由也有各种各样。这就是我们这周的节目——我们为什么要讲述秘密以及讲述之后会发生什么。请继续收听。
Act One, My Own Very Serious Comedy About Women and Food. So let's get into why you might hold on to a secret, why it might be so hard to tell. And if you have an eating disorder or are in recovery for one, a heads up that there's stuff in here that could be triggering.
第一幕，关于女性和食物的严肃喜剧。那么让我们进入为什么你可能会守住一个秘密，为什么它可能那么难说出口。如果你有饮食失调症或正在康复中，请注意这里的内容可能会触动你的情绪。
I want to start by telling you about a movie, one that I saw as a teenager, one that addressed my secret directly. It was an arthouse movie called Eating, subtitle, A Very Serious Comedy About Women and Food. The summer I was 17, my mother and I went to see it together.
我想从一部电影开始讲起，我在青少年时期看过的一部电影，它直接触及了我的秘密。那是一部名为《饮食》的艺术电影，副标题是《关于女性和食物的严肃喜剧》。我17岁那年的夏天，我和母亲一起去看了这部电影。
What are you doing?
你在做什么？
I'd been binge eating for a couple of years by then. In fact, I'm sure I binged before the movie. Sitting next to my mother, I was uneasy. My bingeing was a secret. It was like the movie itself might give me away.
那时候我已经暴饮暴食好几年了。事实上，我很确定我在看电影之前就暴饮暴食过了。坐在母亲旁边，我感到不安。我的暴饮暴食是一个秘密。就好像电影本身可能会让我暴露一样。
You binge, don't you?
你暴饮暴食，对吧？
No, I was just having a--
不，我只是在……
Oh, come on, I've been bingeing since I was your age. I know about bingeing.
哦，算了吧，我从你这个年纪起就开始暴饮暴食了。我很了解暴饮暴食。
Please don't tell my mother I'm eating.
请不要告诉我妈妈我在吃东西。
Do you know how you're going to stop?
你知道你打算怎么停下来吗？
I'm going to quite eating altogether. It's the only way.
我不吃了，完全不吃了。这是唯一的办法。
Quit eating altogether. This was my only way, too. Within a few years after that movie, I was anorexic and back to bingeing, then anorexia again. More years passed, decades. Like some of the women in the movie, I never stopped having an eating disorder.
完全停止进食。这也是我唯一的办法。在那部电影之后的几年里，我患上了厌食症，接着又暴饮暴食，然后又厌食。岁月流逝，几十年过去了。就像电影里的一些女性一样，我从未停止过饮食失调。
I'm never going to ever be able to be like normal people with food. I mean, I'm always going to be at the mercy of it. And it's a very, very scary feeling. It's very, very powerful, and I hate it.
我永远也不可能像正常人那样对待食物。我的意思是，我永远都会受制于它。这是一种非常、非常可怕的感觉。它非常、非常强大，我很讨厌它。
The summer I was 45, I watched Eating again. The first thing I felt was nostalgia-- shoulder pads, bran muffins, Laura Ashley, lines like, "You got a perm."
我45岁那个夏天，我又看了《饮食》。我首先感受到的是怀旧——垫肩、麸皮松饼、劳拉·阿什利，还有“你烫发了”这样的台词。
You got a perm.
你烫发了。
And the second thing I felt was, oh my god, not only is this movie about eating, it's about telling, which was the thing I was obsessed with at that point. The movie is fiction, but it feels like a documentary because a lot of it is women staring into the camera telling personal stories about food.
我感受到的第二件事是，天哪，这部电影不仅是关于吃的，它是关于“讲述”的，这正是当时我所痴迷的事情。这部电影是虚构的，但它感觉像一部纪录片，因为其中大部分内容是女性盯着镜头讲述关于食物的个人故事。
The setting is a 40th birthday party in Los Angeles, and one of the main characters is a filmmaker named Martine. She's making a documentary to help her understand her own eating disorder. I identified with that. At first, Martine tells everyone at the party that her film is about women in southern California. Finally, she owns up to her real subject.
背景是洛杉矶的一场40岁生日派对，主角之一是一位名叫马丁的电影制作人。她正在拍摄一部纪录片，以帮助她理解自己的饮食失调。我对此很有共鸣。起初，马丁告诉派对上的所有人，她的电影是关于南加州的女性。最终，她承认了她真正的主题。
To tell you the truth, my whole documentary is about that-- women and food. That's really why I'm here for.
老实说，我的整部纪录片都是关于那个——女性和食物。那才是我来这里的真正原因。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Why then did you say the documentary was about women in California?
那你为什么说纪录片是关于加州女性的？
Well, actually, it's not a southern California behavior. It's more general. It seem awkward to people when you say women and food. You just start wondering, why women and food? It's the most terrible thing.
好吧，其实这不是南加州的行为。它更普遍。当你提到女性和食物时，人们会感到尴尬。你只会开始想，为什么要谈女性和食物？这是最糟糕的事情。
Just like Martine, I'd hidden my real subject. That eating disorder memoir I was writing, I told people my book was a cultural history of the teenage girl. It actually had started out that way, but it took me a long time to admit what I really wanted to write about. For years, I was ashamed of my own story, same as Martine.
就像马丁一样，我隐藏了自己的真正主题。我当时正在写的关于饮食失调的回忆录，我告诉人们我的书是关于少女文化的历史。它确实是以那种方式开始的，但我花了好长时间才承认我想写的是什么。多年来，我为自己的故事感到羞耻，和马丁一样。
You can say I'm an alcoholic. I feel, oh, I am a drug addict. That's OK. I mean, it's kind of interesting. But just say, I have an eating disorder, I just want to eat, I just want to-- that's so unattractive. It's so disturbing. I just was never able to tell that to anyone.
你可以说我是个酒鬼。我觉得，噢，我是个瘾君子。那没关系。我的意思是，这还有点意思。但只要说，我有饮食失调，我只想吃东西，我只想——那太没有吸引力了。那太令人不安了。我从来没能告诉任何人。
In lots of ways, this movie is dated and judgmental, but it's unapologetically about eating, which still feels radical. One by one, the women come and sit before Martine's camera, and she asks them, tell me, do you have any problem about food? At the end of the movie, she says that hearing their stories has changed things for her.
在很多方面，这部电影已经过时且带有评判性，但它不加掩饰地谈论进食，这仍然感觉很激进。女性们一个接一个地来到马丁的镜头前坐下，她问她们，告诉我，你在食物方面有什么问题吗？在电影结尾，她说倾听她们的故事改变了她。
And I feel so close to them. And it's such a wonderful feeling. It makes me feel I don't want to be alone anymore. I want to be able to share things with other people, you know?
我感觉和她们如此亲近。这真是一种美妙的感觉。这让我觉得我不想再孤单了。我想能够和其他人分享事情，你知道吗？
Maybe this sounds sappy, but these lines did something to me. It's what I wanted, too. I wanted Martine to invite me to sit in front of her camera and ask, do you have any problem about food? I wanted to be Martine, asking others that question. I wanted to be at the party with other women, talking.
也许这听起来很伤感，但这些台词对我产生了一些影响。这也是我想要的。我也想让马丁邀请我坐在她的镜头前问，你在食物方面有什么问题吗？我想成为马丁，问别人那个问题。我想和其他女性一起参加派对，谈话。
I closed my laptop. I went downstairs to the kitchen, and from the freezer I took out a lemon bar the size of a checkerboard square. I put the lemon bar on a plate the size of something a child would use at a tea party. I sliced the bar into strips and then into tiny bites. I sat at the table, and I ate all the bites. Then I wanted more, but I wouldn't let myself have it.
我合上笔记本电脑。我下楼去了厨房，从冰箱里拿出一块像棋盘格大小的柠檬饼。我把柠檬饼放在一个孩子在茶话会上用的那种大小的盘子里。我把饼切成条，然后再切成小块。我坐在桌边，把所有的碎块都吃掉了。然后我还想要更多，但我没让自己吃。
By this point, I'd had enough therapy to understand that what I did with food was what I did with people. Fearful of connection, but so hungry for it. Sitting at the table, I started to fantasize about making my own version of the film, a radio version. I wanted to have a party like in the movie, but I didn't know who I'd invite.
到这个时候，我已经接受了足够的心理治疗，明白我对待食物的方式就是我对待人的方式。害怕建立联系，但又如此渴望联系。坐在桌边，我开始幻想制作我自己的电影版本，一个广播版本。我想要像电影里那样举办一场派对，但我不知道该邀请谁。
A year passed. I got a little better. I told people close to me about my history. I told others. I talked more. Then, my memoir was published. I'd expected to hear from readers who connected with my experience of an eating disorder. What surprised me was how many also connected with my experience of not talking about it. I realized, here were my party guests. I emailed them back with invitations to speak.
一年过去了。我好了一点。我告诉了身边的人我的过往。我告诉了其他人。我谈论得更多了。然后，我的回忆录出版了。我本以为会收到与我有饮食失调经历产生共鸣的读者的来信。令我惊讶的是，有多少人也与我“不谈论它”的经历产生共鸣。我意识到，这就是我的派对嘉宾。我给她们回了邮件，邀请她们谈话。
I've not really had a conversation with another person who has suffered from an eating disorder. And it sounds wild to admit that, but it's true.
我真的没和另一个患有饮食失调症的人进行过交谈。承认这一点听起来很疯狂，但这是真的。
I think this is the most I've ever talked about it. But it's certainly the most I've ever talked about the bingeing side of things and eating other people's food.
我想这是我谈论它谈得最多的一次。但这绝对是我谈论暴饮暴食那方面以及吃别人的食物谈得最多的一次。
And to be honest, aside from my therapist, you are the first person I've ever told about that bingeing, because I am so ashamed of it. I am so ashamed of the way I looked then, what I did then. I just-- I-- yeah, ashamed.
老实说，除了我的治疗师，你是我告诉过暴饮暴食的第一个人，因为我对此感到非常羞耻。我为自己当时的样子、我当时所做的事感到如此羞耻。我只是——我——是的，羞耻。
Have you talked to anybody else besides the nutritionist about this stuff?
除了营养师之外，你还和别人谈论过这些事情吗？
Just you.
只有你。
Yeah. How does it feel to be talking about it?
是的。谈论这些感觉如何？
I'm fine talking about it with you, because I know you really get it.
我和你谈论这些感觉很好，因为我知道你真的懂。
Yeah.
是的。
How does it feel to be talking about this stuff? I asked everyone that question, and I paid attention to what it felt like for me. Sometimes, I felt self-conscious. I seize up in conversation, have more ease when I write. But I also felt the connection I'd craved. I'd never met these women, but I knew them, because we'd been alone in the same ways.
谈论这些事情感觉如何？我问每个人那个问题，我也注意自己是什么感觉。有时，我会感到局促不安。我在谈话中会僵住，但在写作时会更轻松。但我同时也感受到了我所渴望的联系。我从未见过这些女性，但我了解她们，因为我们在以同样的方式独自忍受。
It is such a lonely experience going through daily restriction, purge, and performing all the behaviors of a normal diet without anyone catching on. I mean, I think that sharing stories really does help, because that is the scariest piece, at least for me, of living with an eating disorder is feeling so alone.
经历每日的节食、催吐，并表现出所有正常饮食的行为，而不让任何人察觉，这是一种非常孤独的经历。我的意思是，我认为分享故事确实有帮助，因为那是活在饮食失调中最可怕的部分，至少对我来说，就是感觉如此孤独。
Yeah, I mean-- yeah, me, too.
是的，我的意思是——是的，我也是。
Some of them said, your book made me feel less alone. And when I said back, well, this conversation made me feel less alone, I half worried it sounded insincere and half worried they'd be weirded out if they knew just how sincere I was. And in every conversation, we talked about the thing I was so curious about-- why it was so hard to tell anyone about this stuff or talk about it.
她们中的一些人说，你的书让我感觉没那么孤独了。当我回应说，嗯，这次谈话也让我感觉没那么孤独了，我一半担心这听起来不真诚，一半担心如果她们知道我是多么真诚，她们会感到奇怪。在每一次谈话中，我们都谈到了那个让我如此好奇的事情——为什么谈论这些事情如此困难，或者为什么谈论它如此难。
I think the secrecy, to be honest, is, it's that how eating disorders, at least for me, are deeply tied to sexuality. I think that that's why it's such a hard thing for me to talk about, because it's very much tied to that.
老实说，我认为这种秘密，就是饮食失调——至少对我来说——是与性深度关联的。我认为这就是为什么对我来说谈论它是如此困难，因为它与那个联系得非常紧密。
There's two things. For the anorexia side of it, I think that it's because you don't want people to think you're shallow. I don't want people to think, oh, well, she just wants to be skinny. And with the bingeing, anyone that's never experienced it, you sound out of your mind. It's just, it doesn't make any sense at all. And when you explain it as though it's an addiction and whatever, maybe people have some better sense of it. But it's helpful to talk to someone who's been there.
有两件事。对于厌食症那方面，我认为是因为你不想让人们认为你肤浅。我不想让人们认为，哦，好吧，她只是想变瘦。而对于暴饮暴食，任何从未经历过的人，都会觉得你疯了。它只是，完全说不通。当你把它解释为一种成瘾之类的东西时，也许人们会更好地理解它。但与有相同经历的人谈论是有帮助的。
I think-- I mean, I think for me, one of the reasons why I haven't been able to talk to my therapist about it and get really meaningful help is because I just don't even know how to talk about it. Like, I don't hear other people talk about it. I guess, I kind of know what the vocabulary is, but basically, my only experience is I read other people's books about it. I don't talk to other people about it.
我认为——我的意思是，我认为对我来说，我无法与我的治疗师谈论它并获得真正有意义帮助的原因之一是，我甚至不知道如何谈论它。就像，我听不到别人谈论它。我想，我大概知道词汇是什么，但基本上，我唯一的经验是我读了别人写的关于它的书。我并没有和其他人谈论过它。
Among these women, there was one who was really brand new to talking about her eating disorder, had only recently even identified it as an eating disorder. And that's the conversation I'm going to play next. Because on one level, it's exactly what I'd hoped for-- just a real and good conversation with a woman who shared the experience of having an eating disorder. But also, I think it gets at something important about why we keep any kind of secret. The conversation started the same way as all of them, with Audrey-- that's not her real name-- telling me the history of her eating disorder.
在这些女性中，有一位是刚刚开始谈论她的饮食失调，甚至最近才将其认定为饮食失调。这就是我接下来要播放的谈话。因为在某种程度上，这正是我所希望的——与一位分享过饮食失调经历的女性进行一次真实而美好的谈话。但同时，我认为它触及了我们保守任何秘密原因的重要方面。谈话以和所有人一样的方式开始，奥黛丽——那不是她的真名——告诉我她饮食失调的历史。
I thought nobody else had ever done that. I had never heard of bulimia. I thought I was the only person who had ever done that.
我以为从来没有别人做过那样的事。我从未听说过暴食症。我以为我是唯一一个做过那种事的人。
Audrey is 63, and she started bingeing and purging in college in the 1970s. This was before eating disorders were on after school specials, before bulimia had been defined in a psychological journal. I wondered how Audrey had gotten the idea.
奥黛丽63岁，她在20世纪70年代的大学期间就开始暴饮暴食和催吐。那是在饮食失调出现在课后特别节目之前，在暴食症被定义在心理学期刊之前。我很好奇奥黛丽是怎么想出这个主意的。
Do you remember how it occurred to you to do it, to purge?
你还记得你是怎么想到要这样做，要催吐吗？
I don't remember the initial time, but I had been eating-- as my brain still says, eating like a pig. And I thought, well, I've got to get rid of this. I've got to make up for it somehow. And so, that's what I started doing. And then I would spend my days in the dining hall eating, and then my afternoons finding a bathroom somewhere to get rid of it.
我不记得最初的那一次了，但我一直在吃——就像我大脑仍然说的，像猪一样吃。我想，好吧，我必须摆脱它。我必须以某种方式弥补它。于是，我开始那样做。然后我会整天在食堂吃东西，下午找个厕所把它弄出来。
Audrey kept bingeing and purging. And then she stopped the purging part.
奥黛丽继续暴饮暴食和催吐。然后她停止了催吐的部分。
And what finally stopped me was I went to the health service for something, I don't remember what. And there was a bottle of ipecac on the counter. And when the nurse was out of the room, I stole it.
最终让我停止的是，我因为某件事去了健康服务中心，我不记得是什么了。柜台上有一瓶吐根糖浆。当护士不在房间里时，我偷了它。
Ipecac syrup is used to cause vomiting. It used to be a common thing that people had in their medicine cabinets.
吐根糖浆被用来引起呕吐。它过去是人们药箱里常见的东西。
And I went back to my room, and this was Halloween night-- I remember. And I drank the entire thing, and I got so violently ill.
我回到房间，那是万圣节之夜——我记得。我喝掉了整瓶，然后我病得非常厉害。
Had you used ipecac syrup before to purge?
你以前用过吐根糖浆催吐吗？
No, just a finger.
没有，只是用手指。
And how come you drank the whole bottle?
你为什么要喝掉整瓶？
I was so angry with myself. I was just so angry with myself, I thought, I'm just going to drink this whole damn thing.
我对自己在愤怒。我只是对自己太愤怒了，我想，我干脆把这该死的一整瓶都喝了。
Yeah.
是的。
I knew that anger, knew the feeling of standing in a dorm room hating myself. Audrey told this one story about leaving campus to binge that I so related to. I knew the same shame.
我理解那种愤怒，知道站在宿舍里讨厌自己的感觉。奥黛丽讲了一个关于离开校园去暴饮暴食的故事，我很有共鸣。我有着同样的羞耻感。
I was walking up the street to a chicken place that I knew of, that I knew no other college students went to. And that's why I went there and on my way to a binge. And there was this guy who started walking behind me, and he started whispering at me, big ass. Big ass. And I wasn't scared, I was ashamed. I was embarrassed.
我沿着街道走到一家我知道的炸鸡店，我知道没有其他大学生去那儿。这就是为什么我去那里，在去暴饮暴食的路上。有个家伙开始跟在我后面，他开始对我低语，大屁股。大屁股。我并不害怕，我感到羞耻。我感到尴尬。
I mean, the fact that this guy could have attacked me or whatever his problem was, wasn't-- and I never turned and looked at him. He followed me all the way to the place, and then I went in. And I was embarrassed because-- oh, my god, I forgot this. I was embarrassed because I thought, oh, now he knows where I was going. He knows I was going to eat. Like, that was the problem.
我的意思是，那个家伙可能攻击我或他有什么毛病，这并不是——我从未转身去看他。他一路跟着我到了那家店，然后我进去了。我感到尴尬是因为——哦，天哪，我忘了这个了。我感到尴尬是因为我想，噢，现在他知道我要去哪里了。他知道我要去吃东西。就像，那才是问题所在。
Right. I mean, it just becomes so all-consuming that, of course, that's what everybody else is thinking, because it's the central part of your own experience.
对。我的意思是，它变得如此令人心力交瘁，以至于，当然，那是其他人都在想的事情，因为这是你自己经历的核心部分。
Yeah. I have spent so many years thinking about this. I can't believe it. I mean, really, if you put it all together, years of my life this has been sort of the soundtrack going on underneath everything else.
是的。我花了很多年思考这个问题。我简直不敢相信。我的意思是，真的，如果你把所有这些拼凑在一起，我生命中多年的时间这就像是掩盖在其他一切之下的配乐。
Even as Audrey kept bingeing for most of the next 40 years, that's not what she called it.
尽管奥黛丽在接下来的40年里大部分时间都在暴饮暴食，但那并不是她称呼它的方式。
And then, in your head, it sounds like-- the phrase you used, "eat like a pig"-- is that the phrase you used?
然后，在你脑海里，听起来像是——你用的词组，“像猪一样吃”——那是你用的词组吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I mean, my phrase was "eating bad."
是的，我的词组是“吃坏了”。
Oh my god, when I read that in your book, I thought, I so get it. I so get it.
天哪，当我读到你书里那段时，我想，我太懂了。我太懂了。
Yeah.
是的。
Susan, I didn't know binge eating disorder was a thing, until I read your book.
苏珊，我不知道暴饮暴食症是一回事，直到我读了你的书。
Yeah? So how-- I mean, how did you make sense of it for yourself, without having a name for it?
是吗？那么你是怎么——我的意思是，你是怎么在没有名字的情况下为自己理清它的？
I just thought of it as weakness. I just thought of it as that I was so ridiculously weak that I couldn't stop eating.
我只是把它当作软弱。我只是以为自己太荒谬地软弱了，以至于无法停止吃东西。
Binge-eating disorder is the most common eating disorder, but the least talked about. It only became a formal eating disorder diagnosis a few years back. When I was in college in the early '90s, I spent hours in the stacks reading about eating disorders, and I couldn't find mine in any of the texts.
暴饮暴食症是最常见的饮食失调症，但却是最少被谈论的。它直到几年前才成为正式的饮食失调诊断。20世纪90年代初我在大学时，花了几个小时在书架区阅读关于饮食失调的资料，我在任何教材里都找不到我的那种。
The best I could determine was that I had bulimia without the throwing up, but that seemed like half a problem. I know I had a whole problem-- a real one. I had this kind of fiery, righteous thing going on where I felt like I knew more than the scientists. But my certainty that there was something really wrong with me that I alone had diagnosed did not feel triumphant. It was incredibly isolating to have an experience that I couldn't find named anywhere.
我能确定的最好结果是，我有暴食症但没有呕吐，但这似乎只是半个问题。我知道我有一个完整的问题——一个真正的问题。我当时有一种炽热的、理直气壮的东西，觉得自己比科学家知道的还多。但我确定自己确实出了大问题，而且是我独自诊断出来的，这并没有让我感到胜利。有一种经历却在任何地方都找不到名字，这非常令人孤立。
A binge-- it's eating a lot, all at once, past the point of discomfort. Binge-eating disorder-- I can offer a textbook definition of it here, but Audrey's experience is the textbook definition.
暴饮暴食——就是一次性吃很多东西，超过了舒适的限度。暴饮暴食症——我可以在这里提供教科书式的定义，但奥黛丽的经历就是教科书式的定义。
I just kind of disappear. I just kind of eat. And it's a time in which I feel like everything's OK, actually. While I'm eating, while I'm putting stuff in my mouth, I feel like everything's OK, but I'm kind of not really there.
我只是那种消失了。我只是那种吃东西。这是一个我觉得一切都好的一段时间，事实上。当我吃东西时，当我把东西塞进嘴里时，我觉得一切都好，但我其实并没有真的在那里。
Yeah. How do you feel right after?
是的。你刚吃完感觉如何？
Oh, god awful. Awful. Another day ruined. I mean, and yes, I have felt hopeless. I have felt extremely hopeless, having done it again, and then doing it again the next night. And I felt completely hopeless and out of control of it and hating myself for it.
噢，糟透了。糟糕。又毁了一天。我的意思是，是的，我感到绝望。我感到极度绝望，做了一次又一次，然后第二天晚上又做。我感到彻底绝望，无法控制它，并为此讨厌自己。
That's pretty much the cycle. The anaesthetized feeling during the binge, the self-loathing that follows, feeling like this is out of your control, but also that you should be able to stop, and the secrecy about all of it.
这基本上就是循环。暴饮暴食时的麻木感，随后而来的自我厌恶，感觉这超出了你的控制，但也感觉你应该能够停止，以及对此所有的一切都守口如瓶。
So you didn't tell your roommate senior year. Did you ever want to tell anyone about it?
所以你大四的时候没有告诉室友。你有没有想过告诉任何人？
No. Oh, my gosh, no, I never wanted to tell anybody. No. It was--
没有。噢，天哪，没有，我从来没想过告诉任何人。没有。那是——
Yeah.
是的。
I've been in therapy most of my life, and I have never told any of my therapists about this. It didn't occur to me that I would talk about it.
我一生大部分时间都在接受心理治疗，我从来没告诉过我的治疗师这件事。我没想到我会谈论它。
Why do you think that is?
你认为这是为什么？
I think it's just so embarrassing. And it's really shameful, and it's something that I should be able to handle by myself. I don't know. I think I just kind of blanked it out when I went to therapy to talk. It was too personal, which is bizarre. I mean, I told my therapist all sorts of personal stuff, but that was too embarrassing. And I never thought of myself as having an eating disorder. Binge-eating, I never thought of that as a disorder. I thought of it as a lack of discipline.
我想这只是太尴尬了。而且真的很羞耻，这是我应该能自己处理的事情。我不知道。我想我谈话时只是那种空白了。它太私人了，这很古怪。我的意思是，我告诉过我的治疗师各种各样的私人事情，但那太尴尬了。我从没把自己想成是有饮食失调。暴饮暴食，我从没想过那是一种失调。我以为那缺乏纪律。
Mm-hmm. If you had thought of it as a disorder, do you think that would have made you any more likely to talk about it in therapy?
嗯哼。如果你把它想成是一种失调，你认为那会让你更有可能在治疗中谈论它吗？
Yeah, if I thought it was a disorder, yeah. I mean, I'm from a doctor's family, so anything that can be in a book somewhere, I can accept. So yeah, if I thought of it as a disorder, I probably would have talked about it.
是的，如果我以为它是失调，是的。我的意思是，我是医生世家出身，所以任何能出现在某本书里的东西，我都能接受。所以是的，如果我把它想成是一种失调，我可能会谈论它。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
You know, in your email, you talked about the movie, Eating. And I went to see it, when it came out, with a friend of mine. And we came out of the movie, and we talked about it a little bit, but not a whole lot. It was way too close to home for me. And I don't know if it was too close to home for her, but it was uncomfortable.
你知道，在你的邮件里，你提到了那部电影《饮食》。电影上映时我和我朋友去看了。我们走出影院，稍微聊了一下，但不多。这对我和我朋友来说太贴近现实了。我不知道这对她是不是太贴近现实了，但这很不舒服。
It's so interesting. I'm so glad that you had the experience seeing that movie in the theater when it came out. You're the only person I've ever talked to who's also seen this movie, so this is very exciting for me. So what age were you when you saw that movie in the theater?
太有趣了。我很高兴你在影院上映时有那种看电影的经历。你是我谈过的人中唯一一个也看过这部电影的，所以这对我来说非常令人兴奋。那么你去看那部电影的时候多大？
Oh, well, it was 1990, so-- I don't know.
噢，好吧，那是1990年，所以——我不知道。
So you're in your 30s.
所以你在30多岁。
Yeah, I was in my 30s. And I remember lines from that. I saw it once, but I still remember lines from that movie. I remember there's a woman who's sitting in a jacket, and she says, I'm wearing this jacket because I don't want you to see my arms.
是的，我在30多岁。我记得里面的台词。我只看了一次，但我还记得那部电影里的台词。我记得有个女人穿着一件夹克，她说，我穿这件夹克是因为我不想让你看到我的手臂。
I wear clothes to conceal it. I mean, I have this jacket on because I don't want you to see my fat arms.
我穿衣服来遮盖它。我的意思是，我穿这件夹克是因为我不想让你看到我肥胖的手臂。
And then there's the older woman-- well, she's my age now, but there's the older woman who says, I don't understand these girls. Why don't they just drink?
然后还有那个年纪较大的女人——好吧，她现在和我年纪差不多，但那个年纪较大的女人说，我不明白这些女孩。她们为什么不喝点酒呢？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Food, food, food-- that's all I hear is food. Now, I really enjoy eating, I always have. In my time, we'd get together to have a drink, or cocktails and hors d'oeuvres. I mean, that was always-- that was a more desirable invitation than going to dinner.
食物，食物，食物——我听到的只有食物。现在，我真的很享受吃东西，我一直都这样。在我那个年代，我们会聚在一起喝一杯，或者喝鸡尾酒配开胃菜。我的意思是，那总是——那比去吃晚饭更令人向往的邀请。
And I thought, what is wrong with me? Why don't I just drink? I really did. What is wrong with me? Why don't I just drink, instead of eating?
我想，我怎么了？我为什么不喝点酒呢？我真的这么想过。我怎么了？我为什么不喝酒，而要吃东西呢？
What else do you remember? Do you remember anything else?
你还记得什么？你还记得其他什么吗？
I remember it was really an embarrassing experience watching the movie, and uncomfortable. And the friend I went with is very lighthearted. And then we came out of that movie, and it was pretty dark there for a few minutes.
我记得看那部电影真是一次尴尬的经历，很不舒服。和我一起去的朋友非常无忧无虑。我们走出那部电影，有几分钟时间相当黑暗。
Do you think she connected with it, too?
你认为她也产生了共鸣吗？
My feeling was that she connected with it on the level of women in this culture are told not to eat very much. And she connected with it like a normal person, like a normal woman who suffers under the onus of, you're not supposed to eat too much, but not like somebody like me. But can I ask you something?
我的感觉是，她在这种文化下的女性被告知不要吃太多东西的层面上产生了共鸣。她就像个正常人一样与之共鸣，就像个忍受着“你不应该吃太多”压力的正常女性，但不是像我这样的人。但我能问你一件事吗？
Yeah.
可以。
When you saw it with your mom, do you think your mom was already worried about you, and maybe that's why she didn't really say much about the movie?
当你和你妈妈一起看的时候，你觉得你妈妈当时已经为你担心了吗，也许这就是她没怎么谈论那部电影的原因？
We've talked some now about my eating disorders, and she didn't know about the bingeing. And my mother probably is somewhere on the spectrum of in between eating having been really a destructive force and the friend with whom you saw the movie, who's a woman so she can relate to it on that level.
我们现在已经谈论了一些关于我的饮食失调，她不知道暴饮暴食的事。我母亲可能处于饮食已经真正成为一种破坏性力量和与你一起看电影的朋友之间的光谱上的某个地方，那个朋友是个女性，所以她可以在那个层面上与之产生共鸣。
I'm so glad you understand what I mean by that, about my friend being a normal woman worried about it, as opposed to somebody with a problem worried about it.
我很高兴你理解我的意思，关于我朋友作为“正常女性”在担心，而不是作为“有问题的人”在担心。
Well, I always wanted to be a normal woman worried about it. Yeah.
好吧，我一直想成为一个在担心此事的“正常女性”。是的。
Honestly, that film drove me further underground.
老实说，那部电影把我赶到了更深的地底。
How so?
怎么说？
Because I think because of-- now that I'm thinking about it, I think because of the judgment. It's just thick with judgment of these women and their problems. And I thought, whoa, hm, I was right. This absolutely must remain a secret forever.
因为我认为因为——现在我正在想这件事，我想是因为评判。它充满了对这些女性和她们问题的评判。我想，哇，嗯，我是对的。这绝对必须永远保持为一个秘密。
Yeah.
是的。
And I don't even think consciously of-- I mean, I recently have started thinking consciously about it, but I've never even thought consciously about, gee, I'd better not tell anybody. It's like that would never in a million years have occurred to me to tell somebody.
我甚至都不觉得有意识的——我的意思是，我最近开始有意识地思考它，但我从来没想过，噢，我最好不要告诉任何人。这就像那种事一百万年也不会出现在我想告诉别人的念头里。
What finally prompted Audrey to tell somebody was learning that this thing she did in secret was something that many other people also did and that it had a name. It doesn't always work this way. Naming isn't always something you want.
最终促使奥黛丽告诉别人的原因是，了解到她私下做的事情是许多其他人也做的事情，而且它有一个名字。它并不总是这样起作用。命名并不总是你想要的东西。
I talked to one woman who, for years, didn't tell anyone about her bulimia because she didn't want the label. She didn't want to be saddled with shame she could never shake. As long as she could fix it herself, the eating disorder never existed in the first place. Finally, she did tell, and she did name it, which was terrifying because it made it real. But it also made it more manageable.
我和一位女性谈过，她多年来没告诉任何人她的暴食症，因为她不想要那个标签。她不想背负着她永远无法摆脱的羞耻感。只要她能自己解决，饮食失调在最初就不曾存在过。最终，她确实说了出来，也确实给它起了名字，这很可怕，因为它让它变成了现实。但这也让它更容易控制。
Another woman I talked to was also reluctant to name her eating disorder, not because she didn't want the label, but because she didn't feel she lived up to it.
我和另一位女性谈过，她也很不情愿给自己的饮食失调命名，不是因为她不想要标签，而是因为她觉得自己配不上它。
I just didn't think I qualified. I didn't feel like I was thin enough or sick enough. The images I had in my head of eating disordered people were a very, very rail thin person wearing a hospital gown who's being force fed. That's what I thought.
我只是觉得我不够格。我觉得我不够瘦或病得不够重。我脑海里对饮食失调者的想象是一个穿着病号服被强迫进食的极其极其瘦弱的人。那就是我想的。
This ambivalence about naming was totally familiar to me. When I first went to therapy, it took me a few months to look up my diagnosis code. I was scared to know what was now in my permanent record. And when I looked it up and saw it was anorexia, I got nervous in a new way.
这种关于命名的矛盾心理我完全熟悉。当我第一次接受治疗时，我花了几个月时间去查我的诊断代码。我很害怕知道现在我的永久记录里有什么。当我查到它并看到是厌食症时，我以一种新的方式感到紧张。
Like my therapist didn't understand. I wanted to take off all my clothes and show her that I wasn't thin enough to be anorexic. What I didn't get yet was that, one, you can be anorexic at any size, and two, that my feelings were the essence of the illness. I'm not good enough to be anorexic. I'm not good enough.
就像我的治疗师不理解一样。我想脱掉所有的衣服向她证明我还没瘦到厌食的程度。我还没明白的是，第一，你在任何体重下都可能厌食，第二，我的感受是疾病的本质。我没好到足以厌食。我没好到足以……
A name gave Audrey the words to say the unspeakable. And it gave her the permission she needed to ask for help. After Audrey realized she might have binge-eating disorder, she contacted a nutritionist.
一个名字给了奥黛丽说出那些不可言说之事的词汇。它给了她请求帮助所需要的许可。在奥黛丽意识到她可能患有暴饮暴食症后，她联系了一位营养师。
So I contacted her. And when I emailed it that I thought I might have this problem, I felt OK. But when I called her and we spoke, I couldn't commit. I was like, I don't know if I really have it or not. Maybe I do, I don't know. I don't do it all the time, you know? And she said, well, we don't necessarily have to name it. You may have features of it. And what I thought was, no, no, no, I have it.
所以我联系了她。当我发邮件说我认为我可能有这个问题时，我感觉还可以。但当我给她打电话并交谈时，我无法承诺。我像是，我不知道我是否真的有它。也许我有，我不知道。我并不是一直这样做，你知道吗？她说，嗯，我们不一定非要给它命名。你可能有它的特征。我当时想的是，不，不，不，我有它。
[LAUGHS] Sorry, I'm laughing only because I totally relate, yeah.
[笑声]抱歉，我笑只是因为我完全感同身受，是的。
I know you do.
我知道你懂。
So what feels helpful about talking about it? Or what has felt helpful so far?
那么谈论它感觉哪里有帮助？或者到目前为止感觉哪里有帮助？
What's made a difference, for me, is that it's a named problem. And it's not a failure of character, but a disorder that can be treated.
对我来说，产生了影响的是，这是一个有名字的问题。它不是性格缺陷，而是可以治疗的失调。
Treatment for an eating disorder involves both changing behaviors and addressing the underlying emotional reasons for them. That's exactly what Audrey's doing. In the months since she and I spoke, she's continued with the nutritionist. And now, she's also seeing a therapist. She's not over this yet, but she's working on it.
饮食失调的治疗包括改变行为和解决它们背后的情感原因。那正是奥黛丽正在做的。在她和我交谈后的几个月里，她继续与营养师保持联系。现在，她也在看一位治疗师。她还没摆脱这个问题，但她正在努力。
That's where I am too, but I struggle with a lot of, why can't I just [BLEEP] get over it? Recently, my therapist suggested that I thought that telling my story would release me from shame. I got a little defensive. No, no, I hadn't thought that. But she was right. Telling my story has opened up a lot for me, especially with the people I'm closest to.
那也是我所处的状态，但我与很多想法在挣扎，为什么我就不能该死地克服它？最近，我的治疗师建议说，我以为讲述我的故事会让我从羞耻中解脱出来。我稍微有点防御。不，不，我没想过。但她是对的。讲述我的故事为我打开了很多东西，特别是在我和最亲近的人之间。
But telling is a beginning, not an end. It's not a solution. It doesn't fix your eating. It doesn't release you from shame. To release yourself from shame, you need to understand where the shame comes from. Telling alone doesn't get you there, but it puts you in conversation with people who can help. It gets you to the party with other women, talking.
但讲述是一个开始，而不是结束。它不是一个解决方案。它不能修复你的饮食。它不能让你从羞耻中解脱。要让自己从羞耻中解脱，你需要了解羞耻从何而来。仅仅讲述无法带你到那里，但它让你与能提供帮助的人建立对话。它让你来到有其他女性的派对，进行谈话。
Coming up, keeping your job secret from your children and your children secret from your job. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，对你的孩子隐藏你的工作，对你的工作隐藏你的孩子。马上回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Susan Burton. Today's program, Secrets-- stories about why we tell them and why we don't. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, Bad Cell Service.
这是《美国生活》。我是苏珊·伯顿。今天的节目是“秘密”——关于我们为什么要讲述它们以及为什么我们不讲述它们的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，糟糕的手机信号。
We're told that sharing our secrets will liberate us. We'll feel unburdened, relieved. But sometimes, keeping the secret is what sets us free. Writer Pavan Bivigou has an illness that she's kept secret.
人们告诉我们，分享秘密会解放我们。我们会感到没有负担，如释重负。但有时，保守秘密才是让我们自由的东西。作家帕万·比维古患有一种她一直保守秘密的疾病。
My body has a secret. There are days when my body feels as though it is the secret. If one day you were to pay considerable attention, you might figure it out. My body's quick to breathlessness and slow to recover from exertion.
我的身体有一个秘密。有些日子我的身体感觉好像它就是那个秘密。如果你有一天给予相当多的关注，你也许能弄明白。我的身体容易气促，在剧烈运动后难以恢复。
But perhaps this is too subtle a clue. If I go out drinking and neglect to take my folic acid the morning after, notice how the whites of my eyes have yellowed slightly. This is my body leaking its secret. The yellowed eyes-- this is jaundice, a common symptom of sickle cell disease, which is the secret my body has and tries so hard to keep.
但也许这是一个太微妙的线索。如果我出去喝酒，第二天早上忘了服用叶酸，留意一下我眼白会轻微泛黄。这是我的身体泄露了它的秘密。泛黄的眼睛——这是黄疸，镰状细胞病的常见症状，这也是我的身体拥有并努力想要保守的秘密。
Sickle cell is a blood disorder where red blood cells take on an irregular sickle shape. This diminishes the level of oxygen in the body. It can be painful. The most pronounced pain comes from the unstreamlined cells bumping and scraping along my vessel walls, producing an unbearable rusty ache in my bones, especially at the joints, which sickle cells have trouble squeezing through. And so, often, they logjam and cause swelling.
镰状细胞病是一种血液疾病，红细胞呈现不规则的镰刀形状。这降低了体内的氧气水平。它可能非常痛苦。最明显的痛苦来自那些未流线化的细胞撞击并刮擦我的血管壁，在我骨骼中产生一种无法忍受的锈蚀般的疼痛，特别是在关节处，镰状细胞很难挤过那里。因此，它们经常会交通拥堵并导致肿胀。
All childhood long, I was the sick girl, notable for my string of absences. I was out for days and weeks at a time due to illness, but also for maintenance purposes-- checkups, tests, transfusions. The burden of being my best friend at school was threefold. One, you had to have a back-up best friend for the times I wasn't there. Two, if we started an art project, I had to explain to you how I wanted it done in the very likely event that I wouldn't be there to do it myself. And three, you had to keep up with all the school gossip and catch me up on it in meticulous detail when I returned.
整个童年时代，我都是那个病恹恹的女孩，以一系列缺席而闻名。我经常因为生病而缺席几天甚至几周，但也是为了维护目的——检查、化验、输血。在学校做我最好的朋友，负担有三点。第一，你得有一个备用的最好朋友，以防我不在这里的时候。第二，如果我们开始一个艺术项目，在很可能我不在场无法亲自完成的情况下，我得向你解释我想要怎么做。第三，你得跟上所有的学校八卦，并在我回来时事无巨细地告诉我。
In year nine, I auditioned for the role of a dancing girl in my secondary school's production of "West Side Story." My dance teacher, who was directing, complimented my strong audition and followed up her praise with, if I give you a part in the show, dear, you better promise me that you won't get sick. I won't get sick, I told her hurriedly, without properly considering what she was asking of me. I won't get sick. I repeated it, I'm sure, to reassure myself. I won't, I won't.
九年级时，我参加了中学《西区故事》制作中舞蹈女孩角色的试镜。正在导演的舞蹈老师称赞了我的精彩试镜，并接着说，如果我给你一个节目角色，亲爱的，你最好向我保证你不会生病。我不会生病，我匆忙告诉她，没有适当地考虑她在要求什么。我不会生病。我重复着，我很确定，为了安抚我自己。我不会，我不会。
The following week, the cast list went up. And I was the only year nine dancing girl to get a speaking part. It was one line, but it was everything to me. I prayed, stepped over cracks, wished on stars, did my homework early, my chores diligently, was nice to my brothers-- everything I could possibly think of to be good and stay well. I begged my body to keep the promise I'd made.
接下来的一周，演员名单贴出来了。我是唯一一个获得台词角色的九年级舞蹈女孩。那只有一句台词，但对我来说就是一切。我祈祷、跨过裂缝、对星星许愿、提早做完作业、勤奋地做家务、对兄弟们很好——我能想到的一切，为了表现好并保持健康。我乞求我的身体信守我做出的承诺。
And of course, two weeks before the show, I got sick, the sickest I had ever been, the sickest I have ever been. I caught pneumonia. I was hospitalized for three months, missed five months of school that year. I believe my body did it to spite me. I was so angry, I writhed in my hospital bed in pain and frustration thinking, I'm a girl who wants to dance and say her line. I'm stuck in this body, a place that gets sick. I never auditioned for anything at school ever again.
当然，演出前两周，我生病了，我曾经病得最重的一次，我曾经病得最重的一次。我患上了肺炎。我住院了三个月，那年错过了五个月的学校。我相信我的身体这样做是为了气我。我太生气了，我在病床上痛苦而沮丧地蜷缩着，想着，我是一个想要跳舞并说出她那句台词的女孩。我困在这个身体里，一个会生病的地方。我再也没参加过学校里的任何试镜。
As I grew older, I grew a bit healthier. My body calmed down. I went two years without hospital admission, then five, then eight. Then I mostly stopped speaking about sickle cell and the bad blood that moves inside me. I convinced myself that discussing it would somehow jinx me into more suffering. If I kept quiet about my body, my body, in turn, would keep quiet about its disease.
随着年龄增长，我变得健康了一些。我的身体冷静了下来。我两年没住过院，然后五年，然后八年。然后我基本停止谈论镰状细胞和在我体内流动的坏血。我让自己相信，谈论它会以某种方式让我遭到报应，导致更多的痛苦。如果我保持关于我身体的沉默，作为回报，我的身体也会对它的疾病保持沉默。
I moved through the world less a sick person and more as a person with a sickness. That distinction became very important-- a loophole. I never lied, I neglected to tell the truth. That's how secrets are made.
我走在世界上，与其说是一个病人，不如说是一个患有疾病的人。那种区别变得非常重要——一个漏洞。我从不撒谎，我只是疏忽了说出真相。这就是秘密制造的方式。
My secret allows me to control how people see me. I remember revealing the truth to a co-worker at a bookstore. And after that, he attributed every stumble, every dropped pencil to my sickle cell. I hate to be pitied. Pity says, I'm glad I'm not you. Pity says, I'm glad I do not have to struggle with what you do. Pity feels bad for me, without giving me a chance to feel anything for myself. Keeping my secret is the one thing about my body I can control.
我的秘密让我控制别人如何看待我。我记得向书店的一位同事透露了真相。之后，他把每一次跌倒、每一次掉落铅笔都归咎于我的镰状细胞。我讨厌被怜悯。怜悯说，我很高兴我不是你。怜悯说，我很高兴我不必像你那样挣扎。怜悯觉得我不幸，却没有给我一个机会去为自己感受什么。保守秘密是我身体里唯一能控制的事情。
People would sometimes find out, but it was rare for me to actively tell. My husband is the only person I can remember sitting down to explain. I tell my body's secret only when it is necessary, when it is apparent I'm becoming sick, or when it's a safety concern, like when I fly long distance, because I'd heard that high altitude can trigger a crisis.
人们有时会发现，但我很少主动告诉别人。我的丈夫是我记得唯一坐下来向他解释的人。我只在必要时才说出我身体的秘密，当我明显开始生病时，或者当涉及到安全问题时，比如当我进行长途飞行时，因为我听说高空可能会引发危机。
Years ago, a doctor got me in the habit of taking this precautionary measure. Before the seatbelt light switched on, I walked to the front of the plane and hushedly confessed. The first time I did this, my head swam. It had been so long since I'd said, "I have sickle cell," out loud to anyone. Now, I accept this unburdening as part of my flying ritual. Because it's temporary, the secret remains in the air and dissipates as soon as I land at my destination.
几年前，一位医生让我养成了采取这种预防措施的习惯。在安全带灯亮起之前，我走到飞机前部并低声坦白。我第一次这样做时，头晕目眩。我已经太久没有对任何人说“我有镰状细胞病”了。现在，我接受这种卸下负担的行为作为我飞行仪式的一部分。因为它是暂时的，秘密留在空中，并在我到达目的地落地时立即消散。
Another place I was sometimes OK talking about my sickle cell was in avowedly Black spaces-- home, church, with extended family that wasn't really family. It is our disease, so it's our problem. One theory is that the gene mutation in the hemoglobin evolved to resist malaria. Most people had a cousin back home who had suffered, an aunt's friend of a friend who died from it.
我有时愿意谈论镰状细胞的另一个地方是在公开的黑人空间里——家里、教堂，或者与不是真正亲戚的大家庭。这是我们的疾病，所以这是我们的问题。一种理论认为，血红蛋白的基因突变是为了抵抗疟疾而进化的。大多数人都有一个家乡的表亲患过这种病，或者阿姨的朋友的朋友因此去世。
There was a heavy knowing in these diasporic circles. They understood the specific frustration of being in a body that had an extra thing to contend with. They'd jokingly quote that line from Full Metal Jacket at me-- "Thank god for the sickle cell"-- and I would laugh. In these spaces, I felt seen, but also hyper visible. And as I grew up, I sought out places where I could go incognito.
在这些侨民圈子里有一种沉重的默契。他们理解处在一个不仅要面对生活还要面对额外负担的身体里的特定挫败感。他们会开玩笑地引用《全金属外壳》里的那句台词向我调侃——“感谢上帝给了镰状细胞”——我会笑。在这些空间里，我觉得被看见了，但也过度可见。随着年龄增长，我寻求那种我可以隐藏身份的地方。
I have been told all my life by doctors, teachers, family friends, that I should tell, that it's the only way I will ever feel truly known. I spent so much of my life struggling with this disease, and so, of course, it has shaped me-- the way I form relationships, how suspicious I am of joy, my wholesale resignation to pain, why I hate being cold. Telling people lets them in. But the problem is, I know who I am. I'm a person who has a secret. And so, who do I become if I tell? What do I lose?
医生、老师、家庭朋友一辈子都告诉我，我应该告诉别人，那是让我感到真正被了解的唯一途径。我一生的大部分时间都在与这种疾病作斗争，所以当然，它塑造了我——我建立人际关系的方式、我对快乐的怀疑程度、我对痛苦的彻底顺从、我为什么讨厌寒冷。告诉别人能让他们走进我的世界。但问题是，我知道我是谁。我是一个有秘密的人。所以，如果我说了，我会变成谁？我会失去什么？
I have tried to be more open. I even wrote about my sickle cell for an online publication a few years ago. The positive feedback from strangers was encouraging, overwhelming. But hearing from people I knew felt embarrassing, exposing. Fortunately, it wasn't that many people. I went back to parcelling out the tellings, keeping the information on the strictest need to know basis. And then COVID happened.
我试过更开放一些。几年前，我甚至在一个在线刊物上写过我的镰状细胞。陌生人的积极反馈令人鼓舞、不知所措。但听到我认识的人的反馈感到很尴尬、很暴露。幸运的是，并没有那么多人。我回到了分配讲述的状态，将信息限制在最严格的“有必要告知”的基础上。然后新冠疫情发生了。
At the beginning of it, about a year ago, I received a letter from the Department of Health and Social Care informing me that, as I have a high risk condition, I'm considered extremely vulnerable. And so I must stay out of the way of COVID by staying in my house for at least 12 weeks. Extremely vulnerable is the nicest thing a government organization has ever said about me. Extremely vulnerable made me feel dainty and precious, like a rare jewel, uniquely worthy of special care, until the reality sets in of what it would mean to spend 12 weeks inside my house.
大约一年前，疫情刚开始时，我收到了一封来自卫生和社会保健部的信，通知我，由于我患有高风险疾病，我被认为是极度脆弱的。所以我必须通过待在家里至少12周来远离新冠。极度脆弱是政府机构曾经对我说过的最客气的话。极度脆弱让我觉得娇贵而珍贵，就像一颗稀有的宝石，独特地值得特别照顾，直到现实情况让我意识到在房子里待12周意味着什么。
Could I have lied for 12 weeks, told people I was staying home because I was anxious, overly cautious? Or maybe it would be easier to just tell the truth. And so, for the first time in my life, I slipped into the habit of day to day, face to face, talking about my sickle cell.
我可以撒谎12周吗？告诉别人我待在家里是因为我焦虑、过于谨慎？或者直接说实话可能会更容易。所以，这是我人生中第一次，我养成了每天、面对面谈论我镰状细胞的习惯。
I told friends, new colleagues, neighbors, the postman. They would come by the house, stand at the front gate. I sat the mandated two meters away on the steps, and they would ask me questions. I rambled at them about bone marrow stem cells, rigid red blood cells, anemia, chest crises, increased infection risks, and how scared I was.
我告诉了朋友、新同事、邻居、邮递员。他们会来到房子旁，站在前门栅栏处。我坐在规定的两米外的台阶上，他们会问我问题。我向他们滔滔不绝地讲述骨髓干细胞、僵硬的红细胞、贫血、胸部危机、增加的感染风险，以及我是多么害怕。
Everybody was so nice, so understanding and listening to me. I felt compelled by their kindness to tell, but always sicker after I told. I felt powerless, like a child again. My first adult decision was to keep my illness a secret. I spent so much of my life hiding, to give myself choices as to how I'd move through the world. And now, in revealing myself, I felt trapped.
每个人都那么好、那么理解，并倾听我。由于他们的善意，我感到被迫讲述，但每次讲述完我都觉得更难受。我感到无力，像个孩子一样。我做出的第一个成年决定是保守我疾病的秘密。我一生大部分时间都在躲藏，为了让自己有选择权去决定我如何在这个世界上行进。而现在，在揭露自己时，我感到被困住了。
Once, after a visit where I had told someone, I found myself playing a game I hadn't played since childhood. I lay very still on the floor, trying to pinpoint where in my body my bad blood was moving, imagining the evil broken cells swimming through vessels in my brain, heart, lungs, behind my eyes, across my belly, focusing my thoughts on pulverizing them. It didn't work then, it doesn't work now.
有一次，在一次我告诉别人之后，我发现自己在玩一个自童年以来就没玩过的游戏。我躺在地上纹丝不动，试图找出我体内的坏血正在哪里流动，想象着邪恶破碎的细胞游过我大脑、心脏、肺部的血管，游过我的眼睛后方、腹部，将我的思想集中在摧毁它们上。那时没用，现在也没用。
The most pervasive idea about secrets is that they encumber us. We're told that sharing all the parts of ourselves sets us free, but I have not felt any relief since the knowledge of my condition has become more public. The more I tell the truth to others, the less I feel like me. I would like to return to being sick in the dark.
关于秘密最普遍的看法是，它们累赘着我们。人们告诉我们，分享我们自己的所有部分会让我们自由，但我并没有感到任何解脱，自从我的状况变得更加公开之后。我告诉别人的真话越多，我就越觉得不像我自己。我想回到在黑暗中生病的状态。
Pavan Bivigou is a writer in London.
帕万·比维古是伦敦的一位作家。
Act Three, Mommy's Busy Right Now. Back in March of last year, when schools were shutting down, my co-worker Lina Misitzis saw a tweet from a mother who had a problem lots of mothers had, but a more extreme version of it. She makes porn at home. Her tweet-- quote, "I work when my kids are in school. School is on the verge of closing. It'll be difficult to make content when that happens." A warning-- the story is about someone making porn and keeping it from their kids. You might want to do the same. There's some sexual content. Here's Lina.
第三幕，妈妈现在很忙。去年3月，当学校开始关闭时，我的同事丽娜·米西齐斯看到一位妈妈发的推文，她有一个很多妈妈都有的问题，但是一个更极端的版本。她在家里制作色情内容。她的推文——原文，“我在孩子上学时工作。学校即将关闭。到那时要制作内容将变得很困难。”一个警告——这个故事是关于一个制作色情内容并对其孩子保密的人。你可能也想这样做。有一些性内容。这是丽娜。
Lana makes a la carte porn, short videos of herself for people to buy. And her fans can book her for one-on-one cam shows. We got on the phone in May, two months after that tweet, so, two months into her kids' remote learning.
拉娜制作单点式色情内容，即人们可以购买的关于她自己的短视频。她的粉丝可以预定她进行一对一的视频聊天秀。我们在5月通了电话，在那条推文发布两个月后，也就是孩子们远程学习两个月后。
I'm just going to escape from the teacher YouTube video for a minute.
我只是要从老师的YouTube视频中逃离一会儿。
By the way, Lana's not her real name. It's her performer name. I asked, what is it like now that her family is always home? And she said, basically, it's been tough. The time she used to spend on her own work is now dedicated to the kids' schooling.
顺便说一句，拉娜不是她的真名。这是她的表演艺名。我问，现在她的家人总是待在家里是什么感觉？她说，基本上，这很艰难。她以前用来做自己工作的时间现在都贡献给了孩子们的学校学习。
And then, 5 o'clock, it's just dinner, bath, and bed, as it usually is.
然后，5点，就是晚饭、洗澡和睡觉，和往常一样。
Wait, are you still shooting any content from the house?
等等，你还在家里拍摄任何内容吗？
Not really. I just don't anymore because, after 9 o'clock, I just feel so exhausted now. I just can't-- I can't do it at night.
没怎么拍摄。我只是不再做了，因为在9点之后，我现在感觉太累了。我只是不能——我晚上做不到。
Lana had stopped shooting, which I wasn't so surprised. But then a few minutes after we hung up, I got a text message from her. She wrote, "It's not safe for sex workers to say what they shoot at home while their kids are home." So I called her back right away. It turned out she hadn't been totally honest with me.
拉娜停止了拍摄，我并不感到惊讶。但我们在挂断电话几分钟后，我收到了她的一条短信。她写道，“对于性工作者来说，在孩子们在家时说出她们在家里拍摄什么是不安全的。”所以我马上给她回了电话。原来她对我并没有完全诚实。
You asked me if I made content ever when they're home, I have to. I have to. It's like, being in the closet in your own home. And you're trying to work, and you have to deliver this media to people who have paid already for it. You're under these deadlines to make porn.
你问我是否在她们在家时拍摄过内容，我必须拍摄。我必须。就像，在自己的家里躲进衣柜里一样。你正在尝试工作，你必须把媒体交付给那些已经付过钱的人。你处于完成色情内容的截止日期压力下。
A big reason Lana wasn't immediately upfront-- she doesn't want other moms in her world knowing what she does for work. Lana told me that's because she knows what the other moms think of her job. A couple of years ago, they were passing around a documentary about the dangers of porn.
拉娜没有立即坦白的一个重要原因是——她不想让她世界里的其他妈妈知道她从事什么工作。拉娜告诉我，那是因为她知道其他妈妈对她的工作怎么看。几年前，她们在传看一部关于色情危害的纪录片。
It's vilified. It's something to be afraid of. They look at it as something that's very degrading to women. Like, I'm just degrading myself.
它被妖魔化了。那是令人恐惧的东西。她们将其视为非常贬低女性的事。就像，我只是在贬低我自己。
I really enjoy my own sexuality and being able to tap into that for other people who are looking for something really niche and specific. They don't see it that way at all. They see it as this disease. And if they see me as that, I don't know if they would continue to want to plan play dates with my daughter.
我真的很享受我自己的性，并能够为那些寻找非常小众和特定东西的人挖掘它。她们完全不是这样看的。她们把它视为一种疾病。如果她们那样看我，我不知道她们是否会继续想和我女儿安排游戏约会。
So she's kept her job a secret, for years, from the other moms, and of course, from her own kids. Which just to say, doing your job while your kids are at home, that's one thing. Doing a secret job while your kids are at home, that's a whole other thing. And on top of that, the kids at home, they're also a secret from Lana's customers. For them, Lana has no family. She exists solely in the fantasy they're paying for.
所以她多年来对其他妈妈保守她工作的秘密，当然，也对她自己的孩子保守。这就是说，在孩子在家时做你的工作，是一回事。在孩子在家时做一份秘密工作，那是完全不同的另一回事。除此之外，在家的孩子对拉娜的客户来说也是一个秘密。对他们来说，拉娜没有家庭。她只存在于他们支付报酬的幻想中。
So Lana's having to switch back and forth between these different sides of her life. Each one has to be completely invisible to the other. But she's stunningly can-do about it, very matter of fact whenever I bring up how stressful it seems. Like, it's a puzzle, a bunch of moving parts. All of them have a place, just it needs solving.
所以拉娜必须在她生活的这些不同侧面之间切换。每一个必须对另一个完全隐形。但她对此做得非常出色，每当我提到这看起来有多么令人压力大时，她都很务实。就像，这是一个拼图，一堆移动的零件。它们都有自己的位置，只是需要解决。
OK, so a typical morning, before any kids come downstairs, I'll shoot a small Snapchat clip. One is kind of G rated for my promotional, and the other one is adult for my premium members. So that's done in the morning.
好的，所以一个典型的早晨，在任何孩子下楼之前，我会拍摄一个简短的Snapchat短片。一个是给我推广用的，分级比较温和的，另一个是给我的高级会员用的成人内容的。所以早上就做完了。
Then it's time for the kids to get up, get dressed. She makes them breakfast, situates them for virtual learning. By the way, Lana is married. Her husband knows about and supports her work. But because of the nature of his work, he's often tied up during the day, leaving it to Lana. So while the kids are in Zoom school, she looks for small moments when it makes sense to slip away, or when they're allowed their screen time, occupied by Minecraft or YouTube.
然后是孩子们起床、穿衣服的时候。她给她们做早饭，安排她们虚拟学习。顺便说一句，拉娜已婚。她的丈夫知道并支持她的工作。但由于他工作性质的原因，他白天经常很忙，这留给了拉娜。所以当孩子们在Zoom上网课时，她会寻找一些可以溜走的空档，或者当她们被允许使用屏幕时间，沉迷于Minecraft或YouTube时。
--or I'll even sneak off into the bathroom with the door locked, do a shower scene. Sometimes, there's some pee clips because there's a bunch of pee fans out there.
——或者我甚至会锁上门溜进浴室，做一个淋浴场景。有时，会有一些关于尿的内容，因为外面有一大堆尿液粉丝。
What's interesting, actually, about most of what you just said is that it's the stuff that you'd be doing in the bathroom with the door closed and locked anyway. And you're multitasking.
实际上，你刚才说的大部分内容里有趣的是，那正是你无论如何都会在关上门并锁好的浴室里做的事情。而且你在多任务处理。
Yeah, you work it in. Oh, my god, it's like every time you sit on the toilet, or something, or you turn on the shower, you're like, OK, wait a minute. Should I be shooting this? Because what section of my fans will this be good for?
是的，你会把它融入进去。噢，天哪，就像每次你坐在马桶上，或者什么东西，或者你打开淋浴时，你就像，好的，等一下。我应该拍摄这个吗？因为这对于我粉丝的哪一部分会是好的呢？
The day before, Lana said--
前一天，拉娜说——
I had to go into the kids' bathroom, because that was the room that was the most far away from where everyone else was. And there's towels everywhere. There's an owl picture. The bathroom's painted yellow. It's just not the greatest room for porn. So I have to go in really close and speak kind of quietly.
我必须去孩子们的浴室，因为那个房间离其他人最远。到处都是毛巾。有一张猫头鹰的照片。浴室被漆成了黄色。那真的不是拍色情片的最佳房间。所以我必须靠得很近，声音很小地说话。
Lana's been careful to manage what her kids know about her job. At the time, her daughter was 11, perceptive, starting to have some questions. Sometimes, she'd notice Lana wearing something out of the ordinary beneath her t-shirt and jeans, like full body lingerie or something. And she'd ask her mom, why are you wearing that?
拉娜一直小心翼翼地管理她的孩子对她工作的了解。当时，她女儿11岁，敏锐，开始有一些疑问。有时，她会注意到拉娜在t恤和牛仔裤下面穿着不寻常的东西，比如全身内衣之类的。她会问她妈妈，你为什么穿那个？
And I'll be like, oh, yeah, sorry, this is for work. And she'll be like, mm, OK.
我会说，噢，是的，抱歉，这是为了工作。她会说，嗯，好的。
Do you think it's possible that she just doesn't know that there is more to know than that?
你认为有没有可能她只是不知道除了这个之外还有更多需要知道的东西？
Um--
嗯——
Well, I don't-- I don't remember-- when do kids figure out that sexuality is a commodity?
嗯，我不知道——我不记得了——孩子们什么时候弄明白性是一种商品的？
I think that she is pretty close. She will eventually figure this out.
我认为她已经很接近了。她最终会弄明白的。
Here's what Lana's daughter does know. She knows her mom has a, quote, "grown up job," which is why she has a lot of fun clothes and high heels, which she likes to try on. She knows her mom takes pictures for people and makes videos for them. And she knows that, sometimes, people like to buy her mom's clothes after she's worn them. And that's what she knows. For now, she isn't asking for more. And Lana's waiting for her to ask.
这是拉娜女儿所知道的。她知道她妈妈有一份所谓的“成年人的工作”，这就是为什么她有很多有趣的衣服和高跟鞋，她喜欢试穿。她知道她妈妈为人们拍照片并为他们制作视频。她知道有时人们喜欢买她妈妈穿过的衣服。这就是她所知道的。目前，她没有询问更多。而拉娜在等待她询问。
And her son, he was six when we talked. He didn't know anything about his mom's work yet. He didn't even know it was a door he could knock on. Knocking on doors, by the way, a lesson he should probably learn sooner than later. One time, Lana told me, she snuck off for a quick cam show.
至于她儿子，我们交谈时他6岁。他还不知道关于他妈妈工作的任何事。他甚至不知道那是一扇他可以敲的门。顺便说一句，敲门，这是他可能应该尽早学习的一课。有一次，拉娜告诉我，她溜去进行了一个简短的视频聊天秀。
I went upstairs. I forgot to lock the door. And I had just pulled down my leggings, still had my underwear on. And my son started walking up the stairs. And I'm on camera already, and I had to pull up my pants really fast. And I'm like, hey, what's up? And it's like, my Kindle's not working. And it's like, oh, my god.
我上楼了。我忘了锁门。我刚刚拉下打底裤，还穿着内衣。我儿子开始走上楼梯。我已经开着摄像头了，我必须非常快地拉上裤子。我说，嘿，怎么了？他说，我的Kindle坏了。我想，噢，天哪。
It worked out fine. Lana put the phone down before her son even walked into the room and met him out in the hallway. Actually, almost the exact same thing happened on our phone call, too.
结果一切顺利。在儿子走进房间之前，拉娜就关掉了手机，并在走廊里迎向他。实际上，几乎完全相同的事情在我们的电话上也发生了。
Hold on one moment. What, baby?
等一下。怎么了，宝贝？
Can I have some more Kindle?
我可以再玩一会儿Kindle吗？
She gave him more Kindle. It's not just her kids looking for more screen time, it's also her clients. When the pandemic started, porn consumption in America shot up-- way up. About 25% more streaming, according to the website Pornhub, especially in the middle of the day at around lunchtime-- presumably, people stuck at home.
她给了他更多玩Kindle的时间。不仅仅是她的孩子在寻找更多屏幕时间，她的客户也是。当疫情开始时，美国的色情消费飙升——大幅度飙升。根据Pornhub网站的数据，流媒体播放量增加了约25%，特别是在中午午餐时间左右——据推测，人们被困在家里。
Lana saw an uptick in her fan base, too. Last spring, she told me she'd gained about 8,000 followers on social media and that she was getting more and more requests for private shows.
拉娜的粉丝群也有所增长。去年春天，她告诉我，她在社交媒体上增加了大约8000名粉丝，并且她收到了越来越多要求私人表演的请求。
Everybody right now is at home with their families. And so, men will be working from their home office, and they'll contact me and say, hey, can we do a five-minute cam session?
现在每个人都在家里和家人在一起。所以，男人们会在他们的家庭办公室里工作，他们会联系我说，嘿，我们可以做一个5分钟的视频聊天吗？
Like Lana's doing in her house, these clients are fitting in what they can, when they can, from their houses, many of them hoping it'll go unnoticed.
像拉娜在家里做的那样，这些客户正在从家里尽可能地挤出时间，许多人希望这一切不被注意到。
So that was early in the pandemic, May. Every two or three months, I'd check back with Lana. And every time we'd catch up, she sounded upbeat. And I think, this woman is so good at compartmentalizing. But when I called her back a couple of weeks ago to check in, she sounded different. And she told me she's been having a hard time keeping up her porn persona with clients.
所以那是疫情早期，5月。每两三个月，我会回访拉娜。每次我们交谈时，她听起来都很乐观。我想，这个女人真是擅长把生活分开处理。但几周前我回电确认时，她听起来不一样了。她告诉我她很难保持住她对客户的色情人设。
It's hard to stay motivated, I have found. And it kind of takes a little bit of time to kind of get going and to get in-- I'd have to put on music. I have to sort of get in the mindset to actually create something that's good.
我发现很难保持动力。而且有点需要一些时间来启动和进入状态——我得放音乐。我不得不进入那种心态去真正创造出一些好的东西。
Some things are easier these days. Her kids don't need so much attention during the day. Lana's daughter is old enough to manage her own virtual learning. And her son-- he's seven now-- he's in a small pod with other kiddos his age. Four days a week, he's not at home.
这些日子里有些事情更容易了。她的孩子白天不需要太多关注。拉娜的女儿已经大到可以管理她自己的虚拟学习了。至于她儿子——他现在7岁——他在一个和其他同龄孩子的小组里。每周有四天，他不在家。
Lana even rented a small office for work where she can go spend a few hours each morning shooting by herself. So she has more privacy and doesn't have to toggle back and forth all day between her kids and her secret job anymore. But the pandemic's been getting to her in some new ways.
拉娜甚至租了一个小办公室工作，每天早上她可以去那里花几个小时独自拍摄。所以她有了更多隐私，不必整天在孩子和秘密工作之间来回切换了。但疫情以一些新的方式影响到了她。
There's, I think, a lot of little things, like the gyms being closed and I'm not taking care of my body as well as I did before the pandemic. And so, I feel like my body looks different now, and that makes you not feel quite as sexy when you're looking back at the footage later. And you're like, wow, I really don't like that angle. And so I find myself sometimes just having to bust out content, not because I'm feeling it or because I think this is going to be really great, but it's like, I have to get it done.
我想有很多小事，比如健身房关闭了，我没有像疫情前那样照顾好我的身体。所以，我觉得我的身体现在看起来不一样了，当你以后回顾镜头时，那让你感觉不那么性感。你会想，哇，我真的不喜欢那个角度。所以我发现自己有时只是不得不草率地完成内容，不是因为我感觉到了，或者是因为我认为这将非常棒，而是就像，我必须把它做完。
Actually, Lana says, the hour-long foot worshiping session that she'd done just before this phone call is a good example of what she's talking about. That appointment happened over text. She also sends photos.
实际上，拉娜说，她在这次通话前刚刚做完的、持续一小时的足部崇拜环节是她所谈论内容的一个很好的例子。那次预约是通过短信进行的。她也发照片。
So I'm actually texting with him. And then I'm also looking for a restaurant reservation because I really want to go out to dinner this Friday for outdoor dining. [LAUGHS] And I'm texting with someone else.
所以我实际上是在跟他发短信。然后我同时在寻找餐厅预订，因为我真的很想这周五出去吃晚饭，去户外用餐。[笑声]而且我正在和别人发短信。
Did you get your reservation?
你订到位子了吗？
No, because I have to find a place with heaters and a full bar, and that is a tricky combination right now. [LAUGHS]
没有，因为我必须找一个有暖气和全套酒吧的地方，这在现在是一个很棘手的组合。[笑声]
Like lots of us, Lana's worn down, having less fun on the job. And honestly, who can blame her? But since her whole job is to get other people in the mood, when Lana's not in the mood, that's a different kind of secret, one she can't afford to tell.
像我们很多人一样，拉娜很疲惫，工作时乐趣少了。老实说，谁能怪她呢？但既然她整个工作就是为了让别人有兴致，当拉娜没兴致时，那是另一种秘密，一种她承担不起告诉别人的秘密。
Lina Misitzis is a producer of our show.
丽娜·米西齐斯是我们节目的制片人。
[MUSIC - "SECRETS" BY MARY LAMBERT]
[音乐 - 玛丽·兰伯特的《秘密》]
Our program was produced today by me, Susan Burton. The people who put our show together today include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hilary Elkins, Damien Graef, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker.
我们的节目今天由我苏珊·伯顿制作。今天制作我们节目的人包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔娜·贝克、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、希拉里·埃尔金斯、达米恩·格拉夫、塞思·林德、托宾·洛、米基·米克、丽娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、阿里·萨珀斯坦、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。
Our managing editor is Sara Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Neda Frayha, Andy Lee, Mark Spiegler, and to all the women who trusted me with the stories of their eating disorders. The book I talked about, my memoir, it's called Empty.
我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢内达·弗雷哈、安迪·李、马克·斯皮格勒，以及所有信任我，向我讲述她们饮食失调故事的女性。我谈到的那本书，我的回忆录，书名叫《空》。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, of course, to my boss, Ira Glass, who took the week off to devote himself to his true calling, Star Trek fanfiction. He finished two stories.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费在线收听我们700多集的档案。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。当然，还要感谢我的老板艾拉·格拉斯，他休了一周假，全身心投入到他真正的呼唤中：星际迷航同人小说。他完成了两篇故事。
One is kind of G rated for my promotional, and the other one is adult for my premium members.
一个是给我推广用的，分级比较温和的，另一个是给我的高级会员用的成人内容的。
I'm Susan Burton. Join us next week for more stories of This American Life.
我是苏珊·伯顿。下周请继续收听更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "SECRETS" BY MARY LAMBERT]
[音乐 - 玛丽·兰伯特的《秘密》]